if you're trying to figure out how to
completely erase and reset your mac to
get it ready to sell or give away this
video will show you the simplest way to
do it on any mac regardless of if it's
an intel or apple silicon based machine
but before we get into it be sure to
back up your files by either using time
machine or simply using an external
drive like this thunderbolt 3 ssd which
you can find in amazon linked to in the
description below getting started if
your mac is 2018 or newer click the
apple logo at the top left corner of
your screen and click about this mac to
confirm that you're running mac os
monterey software and if not click on
the software update button and upgrade
to monterey then click the apple logo
again and click system preferences and
click that exact text again in the menu
bar and then finally click on erase all
content and settings and enter your max
password to confirm it'll then show
everything it's automatically handling
like logging you out of your apple id
account so click continue and enter your
apple id password then you can finally
click the red erase all content and
settings button and after a minute or
two you should be greeted with this page
that confirms that your mac is now good
as new and ready to move on to the next
owner now if you have a non t2 chip
intel based mac which is usually 2017 or
older click the apple logo then click
restart before clicking the blue restart
button again and then immediately press
and hold both the command and r keys
until the apple logo and loading bar
show up then click on disk utility and
within the sidebar click on the
macintosh hd option that has your data
installed then click on the erase button
and finally click erase volume group if
you have that option once it's finished
click disk utility in the menu bar then
quit disk utility then click on
reinstall mac os and then finally go
through the installation process to get
it ready for the next owner and boom
there you go you're all set so hopefully
this video was helpful and if it was go
ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe if you want to see more tech
related videos like our 14 inch macbook
pro review which you can check out right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]